- [Voiceover] In the last couple videos
I've been talking about
curl where if we have
a two dimensional vector field V
defined with component functions P and Q,
I've said that the 2D
curl of that function V
gives you a new function that
also takes in x and y's inputs
and it's formula is the
partial derivative of Q
with respect to x
minus the partial derivative
of P with respect to y.
And my hope is that this
is more than just a formula
and that you can understand
how this represents fluid
rotation in two dimensions
but what I want to do here is show
how the original intuition
I gave for this formula
might be a little oversimplified
because for example, if we look at this,
the partial Q, partial x component,
I said that you can imagine
that Q at some point
starting off a little bit
negative so the y component
of the output is a little negative,
then as you move positively
in the x direction,
it goes to being zero
and then it goes to being
a little bit positive,
and with this particular picture,
it's hopefully a little bit
clear why this can correspond
to counter-clockwise
rotation in the fluid,
but this is only a very
specific circumstance
for what partial Q,
partial x being positive
could look like.
It might also look like Q's
starting a little bit positive
and then as you move in the x direction,
it becomes even more positive
and then even more positive.
And according to the formula,
this should contribute
as much to positive curl
as this very clear-cut whirlpool example,
and to illustrate what
this might look like,
if we take a look at
this vector field here,
if we look at the center, this is kinda
the clear-cut whirlpool
counter-clockwise rotation example.
And if we play the fluid
flow, the fluid does indeed
rotate counter-clockwise in the region.
But contrast that with what
goes on over here on the right.
This doesn't look like
rotation in that sense at all.
Instead the fluid
particles are just kind of
rushing up through it.
But in fact, the curl in
this region is going to be
just as strong as it is over here,
and I'll show that with a formula
and kind of computing it
through in just a moment,
but the image that you
might have in your mind
is to imagine a paddle wheel of sorts
where let's say it's got
arms kind of like that
and then you hold down with
your thumb that middle portion,
so even though the paddle
wheel left to its own devices
would just fly up, I want to say,
let's say you're holding
that down with your thumb
but it's free to rotate.
Then the vectors on its
left are pointing up
but less strongly than
the vectors on its right
which are even greater, so
if you imagine that setup
and you have your paddle wheel there,
then when you play the fluid rotation,
holding your thumb down
but letting the paddle
wheel rotate freely,
it's also going to rotate just as it would
over here in the easier
to see whirlpool example.
And in terms of the formula,
this is because a situation
like this one here,
where Q goes from being
negative to zero to positive,
should be treated just the
same as a situation like this
as far as 2d curls is concerned,
because this term in the 2d curl formula
is going to come out the
same for either one of these.
And it's worth pointing out, by the way,
curl isn't something that
mathematicians and physicists
came across trying to
understand fluid flow.
Instead, they found this
term as being significant
and various other
formulas and circumstances
and I think electromagnetism
might be where
it originally came about.
But then in trying to
understand this formula,
they realized that you can give
a fluid flow interpretation
that gives a very deep
understanding of what's going on
beyond just the symbols themselves.
So let me go ahead and
walk through this example
in terms of the formula
representing the vector field.
It's a relatively
straightforward formula actually.
So P and Q,
that x component is going to be negative y
and the y component, Q, is equal to x.
So when we apply our 2d curl formula
and apply the partial Q with respect to x,
so partial of this second
component with respect to x
is just one,
and then we subtract off the
partial of P with respect to y
which up here is negative one
because P is just equal to negative y.
So the 2d curl is equal to two
and in particular, it's a constant two
that doesn't depend on x and
y, which is pretty unusual,
most times that you apply
2d curl to a vector field
you're going to get some
kind of function of x and y.
But the fact that this is constant,
tells us that when we look
over at this fluid flow,
the sense in which curl,
the formula for curl
wants to say that rotation
happens around the center
is just as strong as
it's supposed to happen
over here on the right,
or anywhere on the plane for that matter.
So if we're playing this
and if you imagine you have
the paddle wheel in the center,
evidently it would be
rotating just as quickly
as the paddle on the right
even though it might,
I don't know, to me, that
feels a little unintuitive
cause the one on the right I'm thinking,
okay, you know, maybe there's
a little bit more torque
on the right side than
there is on the left
and that's kind of a
counter-balancing act,
but the idea that that's actually the same
as the very clear-cut, I see
the counter-clockwise rotation
with my eyes, example in the center,
does seem a little unusual.
But I think it's important to understand
what else two dimensional
curl can look like
and what else this formula
might be representing.
So with that, I'll see you next video.